hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dead man's journey now
you are someone that has done something
very bad I don't know what it is but
you're stuck in purgatory and you have
to evaluate whether you're going to
heaven or oh please just the volume
until you can vary slightly you're a
beeping sound is it just [ __ ] with me
I think it might be [ __ ] with me
trying to get my volume all the way up I
won't be fooled even though I always
have my volume up anyway you heard the
man crank up your volume to maximum I
don't want any excuses you get out of
that comment section you're in this with
me forever so let's do this together as
one until I run away screaming like a
little baby leave you behind to die by
the monster include a valid reason to
start over new monotonicity nice
thoughts and experiences final of worthy
aside
no not at all hello Oh sad dar is this
purgatory am I in the wasteland of lost
sins
oh when hanging in between life and
death heaven in hell one can only do but
remind himself over and over why what do
I remind myself whoa hello this is the
doorway oh there's a weird interactive
panel for being purgatory didn't oh hey
did something happen
oh I can see something in there ooh ah
okay for that oh it's just the game
brightness through the number keys it's
kind of dark oh oh ooh oh whoa I'll do
five I'll go right in the middle poink
oh [ __ ] yeah I wouldn't been able to see
that okay well then I'm ready to be
spooked are you ready to spook me right
I honestly have no idea what the quality
of this game whenever I go into these
indie horror games I really don't know
what to expect but it seems Albrighton
cheerful so it's probably gonna be okay
anybody over here nope do not leave door
open or unlocked
okay what's gonna happen
ah another gate okay
okay oh no it's gonna be a PT thing cool
I love PT thing okay so there's nothing
still over here am I just gonna be
looping back and forth forever
is this what purgatory is oh no you
don't own or you don't
oh who did that did someone knock these
over oh no oh no hi are you gay I'm not
going back
[ __ ] off with you [ __ ] off with you okay
I'm going forward that's the only thing
to do when you're stuck in purgatory I
don't know if there's any point to going
over here I'm probably abandoned going
over here from now on just continue
straight on because I don't know what's
expecting me I don't know if anything's
expecting me should I be expecting
something or someone oh I couldn't
interact with it Oh is there something I
miss is it gonna be something else
waiting for me uh-huh [ __ ] you alrighty
then huh you want to miss huh brah okay
do I gotta go back oh can i oh alright
then I gotta turn down the sensitive e
on my microphone only prepared for
something like this yeah yeah yeah okay
got it huh all right I'm gonna try this
again okay bye I'm sure there was
nothing actually over there and
everything's hunky-dory in my life in
hell
raiveer be oh the door is open now
cool should I go oh [ __ ]
well that answers a question alright
fine Oh God uh okay well then this is
Zen front of mind well that's not a good
sound okay I'm gonna leave now
yeah good cheer on the men around this
Bend goddamn oh cool
everybody I love the way this okay all
right okay all right Oh
Oh God oh great uh-huh all right going
down the stairway where am I going
where does this lead to me Olo i press
key 23 Brad legal doctor Southwest that
drive two exits no dog kill them oh okay
that's a strange note wait what else was
on that bed something about America
great good to know okay yup
i paws eyes that was not that scary I am
a big [ __ ] and that shouldn't have
happened
I apologize I apologize hello
both mother and son die treat each
clearity chicly in the hands of the
father police arrived at a home on
Thursday night after a worried neighbor
called in to report excessive screaming
on police forcefully entering the home
both believed to be mother and son were
brutally murdered with the father
nowhere to be found full-on
investigations have begun to take place
so is this my brutal sin not at all aha
unforgettable that's what I do early all
right oh yeah this is gonna be the same
thing is that my heart I hear something
too my heart my big bubble blowing baby
heart they're gonna come popping out of
me again yeah can't get wavy with a same
thing other place all right oh [ __ ] you
I do oh hey hi
horse [ __ ] all right fine you know what
I'm brave I'm a brave man I'm willing to
go into the darkness
wherever that mainly oh god damn I
forgot to charge
I like acknowledged that I had a charge
in my mind I just never said it out loud
okay does anybody not want me to walk in
on them in the bathroom again that was
awfully rude of me
okay upon investigating police
determined the husband of Clara Nene and
father of Robert cut Claire up into
pieces to later stuff her into the oven
alongside her son while alive it has
been over 20 years since such a horrific
act took place many neighbors in shock
attempt to sell their property with no
luck police witness the results require
therapy well
most batteries damn parently dices okay
alright that was so easy I worried for
nothing that little [ __ ] got my shirt
dirty though things burned perfectly at
500 degrees seven seven nine three I'm
assuming that's important seven seven
nine three so repeat with me everybody
seven seven nine three seven seven nine
three seven seven nine three okay
carrying on oh forget it seven seven
nine three
looky there ha [ __ ] off with you and
dick eating [ __ ] you also eat dicks what
I meant to say listen [ __ ] you [ __ ] off
you are you want to [ __ ] with me huh
okay you want to [ __ ] on me no okay so
is this done yet no okay right then okay
so who else is around here seven seven
nine three and who wants to mess with me
seven seven nine three I'm gonna come
charging at the monster screaming seven
seven nine three at the top of my
goddamn lungs anybody out here anybody
at all huh
uh-huh can I go yeah okay sir
9mm dad Oh Marty okay wink yay it sounds
like I did it right but why did it sound
so horrible and almost as if a bomb was
gonna float yeah well no time to worry
about that
got to keep pressing on waiting for the
next jump scare right around the corner
it's gonna be great
whoa is he doing a dance move there what
was that that was it was a lot funnier
than it was scary okay you didn't want
to jump scare me he just wanted to show
me he was able to have fun too
we all have fun here there's good times
all around I appreciate it very much
though
I like ride but why is you red is there
any particular reason no okay well now
that I don't need to worry about 77093
anymore sorry I think I [ __ ] my pants
happen again all right down here I can't
quite identify those sounds need to be
more specific to me father of murdered
family has been sentenced to death after
constant cries of innocence upon further
investigation has included that young
Amy Rin has stayed at her grandparents
over to the night of the massacre and
John uhrin remains missing from five
years ago grandparents say he ran away
from his house at 16 years old what what
does that mean who are whose Amy and
John what who are these people
okay what later Gordon huh yeah what a
naughty person I is mom finally bought
me my own phone my phone number is four
one nine nine four eight seven seven
nine three does that mean that's
obviously the phone number that was on
the note but why did it say kill them
all above it my brother was born in
77 and my sister in 1993 those years I
would never forget to zero reason that T
is capitalized 1977 to 1993 1977 and
1993
remember that 1977 in 1993 nineteen
seventy seven seventy seven 93 77 93 77
93 oh wait I get it you're taking a
boopy boopy boopy boopy you're pooping
you're pooping pooping never mom going
upstairs now
1977 1993 well 77 what the [ __ ] man
alright so 7 1977 and 93 that's 77 93
was [ __ ] you where's that fall from
nothing up there so 1790s is in Lane
three I'm so sorry I'll die tomorrow to
be with you promise okay thanks I was
worried about that one you always come
through with your promises for me so 77
and 93 oh wow oh we're going at it ass
backwards this time cool me likey this
but why what is this do it alright I'll
go down why though okay qualify
everything find them um I had no idea it
was them I haven't seen them for six
years how could I forget their faces so
soon the things I've done to them how I
killed them it's impossible to live on
what does that mean Who am I who
murdered these people am I the father
and who are you talking about haven't
seen them for six years I know I do it
was damn good
oh I don't know oh yeah sure
okay I get it now
is anyone still in there doo doo doo
okay I gotta go eventually so you got to
get out of there but I won't worry about
it too much
ooh right up here but okay that makes me
uh uh alright jiggle-jiggle okay I'll go
back down I guess it's finally my turn
to go to the bathroom
goodbye down here anybody anybody okay
uh hi friend
oh okay well well no don't leave me in
here with him not happen okay what do I
do
I just oh hey good morning
oh boy okay whoa wow that's so cool good
boy huh yeah I get that out of your hat
Super Grover okay
but you know I mean okay yeah it seems
pretty cut-and-dry not to make a pun out
of it but walk off with you hello ah
lovely that
lovely okay so I get what I did now feel
free to continually punish me
I don't mind anymore this is a really
cool game by the way I actually really
like this there's some things about
mmm-hmm I really admire this by the way
because you know obviously there's some
things that seem hokey on the surface
but that's just because you know this
probably was made by one person or a
very small team group I didn't know
anything see I wasn't there because on
your body will get six useful by the
help we give you faster the chicken
Caesar okay the motive there is a little
convert press one for heaven press two
for hell well if I had to go based on
what this seems to be I pretty much
doubt and I'm gonna go with option
number one so let's see what's behind
door number two I mean just judging by
the papers or a murderous individual
person
in spending Lord for my time as a
masculine through the memories that he
had already done okay this time the D
promotion fee be accessed and projected
upon him when he brought me when he said
I will be taken once and decided every
chemisty a heaven or hell maybe best
suited for you with that said is to us
huh - be wasted I appreciate flawed
at the end
yeah that was good that was good that
was really good I mean it was good
because like here it's obviously this
was made by one person but I was good
the story was convoluted and I've had a
lot of plot holes and you know I
couldn't tell if he was trying to get me
to feel sorry for this guy that
seemingly unapologetically murdered his
whole family cut them up and burned them
alive so I don't think I was supposed to
be in any way agreeable to that outcome
but I had fun I mean the looping
mechanic is kind of like you know uh you
know I love it you know I I don't care
how many times it's done not that it's
been done as many times there's other
horror tropes but I love it love it love
it love it I like that that was fun
great stuff I appreciate it
this was cool I enjoyed it it got me a
couple times it made me laugh a few
other times because it was just a little
hokey but even so though I liked it so I
hope you liked it too let me know what
you thought in the comments below and
check out the other scary games that I
played and you can check out the link to
the scrim I'm getting in the description
below I can't talk but thank you
everybody again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye